you might remember that the rapper tom
mcdonald came out with a song a few
months ago snowflakes it went
viral it hit top of the charts
as your humble cultural correspondent we
took a look at it on the show you know
hip-hop and stuff is not exactly my cup
of tea but i did get a kick out of the
video
well i can't wait now i have not heard
tom's new song the producers assure me
it's terrific so they are going to play
it for me
i will give you my expertise in the
culture
in real time
[Music]
half the country fell asleep but they
scream woke were distracted by vaccines
and tv shows politics celebrity gossip
popular neat quotes black lives white
lives which lives mean most we only
dedicate one day to remember our fallen
soldiers the men and women who died
young
but if you come out the closet is
caitlyn jenner you're a hero and you get
a whole pride month the most dangerous
pandemics propaganda from these clowns
only mass that's going to save us is
duct tape on their mouths don't speak we
don't need the deformed police need to
deform the media who lies through their
teeth like big farmer doesn't cure you
dog cause every patient that gets cured
is a customer lost and big oil runs the
world the only wars to get fought are
with the countries who have natural
resources they want heard him claiming
if a white man braids his hair and likes
rap he's appropriating culture but if a
white man acts too white he's white
trash he's a racist he's a bigot he's a
monster let's just have the conversation
not every liberal is dumb not all
republicans are racist
the government wants everybody fighting
with their neighbors cause they know
that if we get along we'll probably go
against them
they can't stop
ready us fight trying to brainwash us
but we won't let freedom die
the whole world's brainwashed
everybody pick a team started right in
the streets the whole world's
brainwashed
how did monkeys become people and people
turned into sheep they put fluoride in
the water that's keeping us all asleep
claiming they want what's best for us i
find it hard to believe cause they've
been selling a cigarette since we was
18. poison right there uh you know
so i want to keep it going but i i
really love where he's going with this
because he's not
he's not just reciting sort of
traditional the libs are bad you know
and conservatives are good or whatever
vice versa he's really getting much more
at the heart of the problem which is
that there is this
something sometimes called the uniparty
or the liberal establishment or the blob
it's just
it's this structure
wherein many of our political battles
are just fake they're just not real
they're ju it's like play acting you
know you'll they'll put up the
republican the republican is mitt romney
and he's going to go up against the
democrat barack obama and actually they
agree on basically everything and
actually mitt romney invented obamacare
and actually it's just a kind of a farce
it's just a play and
in terms of the real
wishes of the american people whether
it's on immigration drastically reducing
immigration which most americans want
whether it's winding down some of these
wars of empire overseas whether it's
getting back some of our traditional
american liberties and
pushing the surveillance state a little
further away from us
neither party is really representing
them so and and so what what he's
recognizing is it's all just a tv show
it's all and the media obviously the
corporate media are kind of the
the main propagators of that but it's
everywhere this goes a level
a little bit deeper you know as long as
they can keep americans divided and
focused on race or something like that
then we won't pay attention to the way
that the
the regime operates the way that the
ruling class is actually governing us
keep going fake news fake woke distract
and divide you're either right or you're
left or you're black or you're white big
tech don't need a microchip to hack in
your life cause the phone inside your
pocket is a tracking device pause right
there this is great i love this because
you saw he went after the vaccines which
i like i mean not because i actually
don't think the vaccines are going to
pump you full of 5g microchips and make
your cell phone work better but i i
don't like the idea that the government
and the blob it's sort of proxy private
institutions are now forcing people to
get this experimental drug that does not
have full fda approval and even if it
did for people who
do not actually face a particularly
grave risk from the coronavirus
something about young people and healthy
people and they're really forcing it on
everybody and what he's saying here is
yeah sure the vaccine thing that's
that's not great but
they don't need them they don't need the
microchips like some of the wildest
claims and unfounded theories they don't
need the microchips
they're already tracking you in your
cell phone and on your laptop and on
your ipad and on your fridge and on your
microwave and your tv and everywhere
everywhere the surveillance state has
now fully embedded itself into into the
way that our economy works and it's it's
the government in part
it's so-called private companies in part
like google but then google owns
multiple entities with the government so
that line is a little bit blurry spot on
tom keep going and i don't know what i'm
sick of rappers or joel biden looking
like he ate a hundred xanax for dinner
cause censoring the president and
kicking him off twitter is a bigger
threat to freedom than foreign
[Music]
why would you be comfortable if police
and the government the only people on
the planet with the right to buy a gun
white privilege getting amplified to
reinforce division it convinces white
people that they're favored by their
skin and black people getting angry
because they're told they're treated
different so the conflict is between us
and never with the system let's just
have the conversation not every liberal
is dumb not all republicans are racist
the government wants everybody fighting
with their neighbors because they know
that if we get along we'll probably go
against them
they can't stop us
cause we're ready to fight trying to
brainwash us
but we won't let freedom die the whole
world's brainwashed
[Music]
infiltrate adults with the news step
three indoctrinate the children through
the schools and the music and the apps
on the phones that they use step four
separate the right from the left step
five separate the white from the black
step six separate the rich from the poor
use religion and equality to separate
them more step seven fabricate a problem
made a lie step eight put it on the news
every night step nine when people start
to fight and divide take control this is
called situational design uh pause it
right there
so
some some of this i think goes a little
too far and you hear this a lot
especially from the left where they'll
say hey you know they're just dividing
us on these superficial distinctions
between forget about black or white or
geography or anything like that but then
they'll get into like
religion for instance you say oh these
superficial distinctions but actually
those distinctions do matter religious
ideas do matter if bottom all human
conflict is theological so the
government right now
has many religious ideas of religious
ideas about the nature of government
the relationship of man to the state the
relationship of man to his own person
you know they have the the sort of
agnostic idea about transgenderism i
think most of the american people don't
think that that you know you can be a
man but actually really be a woman but
but the the government the establishment
does have that idea that is a religious
divide i mean some of the some of those
things are real it's not so easy to say
it's us versus
them you know us we the people versus
the government the other thing i might
disagree with tom a little bit here i
hope he's right but he says you can't
stop us because we're ready to fight i
hope we're ready to fight
i hope that we're ready to use our
political power
to push back against this establishment
i don't know that we are i actually
think in in many ways the the regime is
holding on to power pretty well keep
going tom trying to brainwash us
but we won't let freedom die the whole
world
[Music]
i loved it i loved it it's great you
know
a couple minor disagreements here there
maybe on certain lines otherwise this
guy's spot on me this guy
understands politics better than
probably 90 percent of mainstream
political commentators
and he's he's a tatted up rapper great
stuff really
wait way to go tom i mean i'm not
exactly the primary audience for rap and
hip-hop but i really enjoyed that good
stuff
[Music]
[Music]
you